thank you to true bill for sponsoring
today's video truebill helps you reach
your financial goals by canceling
unwanted subscriptions negotiating bills
on your behalf and budgeting download
truebill for free by heading to
trubill.commicrocosmos or by clicking
the link in the video description
[Music]
[Music]
our master of microscopes james doesn't
live particularly close to the sea but
as we've seen in some previous episodes
that distance has not stopped him from
finding ways to explore marine life
if he can't easily get to the sea well
the sea can be brought to him in monthly
deliveries of sand and sea
so among all the other microbe
collections in his home james has fish
tanks with no fish
just archives of those marine deliveries
and some of those tanks have been around
for a while so you might think that he'd
found everything he was going to find in
them but the sea is always delivering
new surprises even when it's been firmly
encased in a fish tank for more than a
year
recently one of these old tanks turned
up some surprising tentacled creatures
at first glance james thought they might
be a journey to the micro cosmos
favorite the hydra
except hydra don't particularly care for
salt water they are fresh water
creatures so naturally james decided to
take a closer look studying his
miniature creatures under the microscope
he could see rows of tentacles attached
to a pod so with this in mind james
began digging through his books on
cnidaria the phylum that hydras belonged
to and he narrowed in on a possible
species the mauricia
that name may not mean anything to you
right now but when james saw it it made
him realize something else somewhere in
his tank
there must be a jellyfish
now to understand why james had this
realization you need to first hear a
little bit more about how the mauricia
actually lives
an important part of that is that the
mauricia actually has two lives
[Music]
mauricia are a type of hydrozoon a group
of cnidarians that includes about 3 700
species while they are not as well
studied as other famous hydrozoons like
the hydra or the portuguese mana war we
do know that several mauritius species
likely originated in the black sea but
have since spread widely even found in
estuaries in the united states their
spread has probably been helped by the
fact that they are able to withstand a
wide range of temperatures and
salinities making it easy for them to
navigate new waters they survive on
zooplankton like our favorite crustacean
the copepod and as we said earlier the
mauricia has two lives one as we've been
observing is the polyp form and the
other is this
the medusa or as james named it squishy
the jellyfish
the double life is a common hydrozoon
trait though we should note that hydras
are a notable exception living strictly
in a polyp form
but for hydrozoons like the mauricia
things are a little more complex when
they hatch they emerge from an egg as a
larva called a planula which settles
onto the ground and develops into a
single polyp radially symmetric and
usually attached to objects like plants
shells or rocks and from there the
polyps begin to bud forming more and
more polyps until there's a whole colony
of them attached to each other
within this colony polyps can take on
different forms to serve different
functions some might take on spiny
tentacles that allow them to defend the
colony while others have mouths
dedicated to eating still others might
be dedicated strictly to reproductive
function the polyp stage is clearly
distinct from the medusa stage one looks
more like a diffuse tree while the other
looks like a bag with strings dangling
off of it but the real crux of their
difference is not in their appearance
but in their reproduction because
hydrozones can reproduce in both stages
just very differently as a polyp it
reproduces asexually butting off to form
new polyps and eventually to form the
medusa you can see the polyp actually
butting off to create this next stage of
life that little nub eventually
expanding and releasing to create what
will end up resembling an inverted polyp
or an umbrella and unlike the sessile
anchored polyp medusas are free swimming
inside its opening is an inner ring of
tissue called the vellum which helps the
medusa move around by tensing up and
relaxing for this mauricia species the
medusa are phototaxic meaning they like
swimming toward light that's actually
how james found them in his tank after
identifying the possible species and
reading that they like to swim toward
light he decided to check the side of
his tank that received all the morning
sunshine when he did he found his tiny
jellies but the main function of this
form is less about light and more about
sex
in mauricia that have been raised in the
lab the medusa takes about eight days to
develop gonads and when they do they
will proceed to their next step
sex
the exact details of how hydrozoans have
sex varies with different species and we
haven't been able to find an answer to
exactly how the mauricia do it in the
literature but we want to briefly state
that one of the hydrozoon possibilities
is that the male releases sperm into the
water and the female releases eggs that
chemically attract the sperm to them the
fertilization is entirely external just
happening in the water and eventually
that fertilized egg will develop into a
new organism
here's an important question though why
the double life why two different stages
that can each reproduce in completely
different ways
well because asexual and sexual
reproduction are both
pretty nifty talents to have on hand
asexual reproduction is fast and it
helps polyps build their local
populations quickly the downside is that
an asexual polyp means limiting both the
scenery and the gene pool
with that comes the risk that the
environment will shift suddenly and both
the polyp and the entire population will
be unable to adapt fast enough to
survive
but by leading a second sexually
reproductive life as a medusa the
hydrozoon gets to disperse both
physically and genetically but there is
a cost after all sexual reproduction
takes time and special organs and the
hope that sperm will meet an egg but
that is why the hydrozoon doesn't
strictly rely on sexual reproduction
either this combined strategy is part of
why the mauricia has been so successful
at traveling beyond its origins
it gets the best of both worlds as an
organism that is at times static and
dividing and at other times swimming and
mixing each generation produces a large
local population that can eventually
expand and spread
we should here at the end however admit
one thing
technically our squishy the jellyfish
is not
a true jellyfish
to be considered a true jellyfish an
animal has to be a member of the class
cyphozoa and cyphozoa like the hydrozoa
are part of the cnidarian phylum so
while mauricia and their fellow medusa
hydrozoa do bear a strong resemblance
and relationship to their true jelly
relatives they also have their own
unique structures that make them
distinct and alas not true jellyfish but
in our tank of seawater squishy the
jellyfish will keep his title he has
worked and traveled a long way to earn
it
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you to true
bill for sponsoring this video still
searching for a new year's resolution
that you can actually keep how about
getting rid of a few of the streaming
services that you barely remember
signing up for and very often forget you
even have or maybe just try feel more in
control of your finances in the new year
either way truebill is there to help you
out truebill is an all-in-one personal
finance app that helps you take control
of your financial life helping you save
more and spend less with true build you
securely connect your financial accounts
and they will take care of the rest this
personal finance manager tracks all your
subscriptions in one place cancels
unwanted ones with just a tap by safely
and securely identifying recurring
charges it can even negotiate your bills
for you while also monitoring your
credit score and automating your savings
and you can do all of this with just one
app download trubil for free today by
heading to trubill.com microcosmos or by
clicking the link in the description
there's a bunch of names coming up on
your screen right now they are the
people who make this channel possible
they are our patrons on patreon they are
people who saw
chill
weird interesting microscopy videos on
youtube and they were like i want to
watch more of those and then they
watched a few more and they decided to
go to patreon.com journey2micro so if
you're looking for someone to thank
those are the people if you want to see
more from our master of microscopes
james weiss check out jam and germs on
instagram or tick tock or you can go and
pick up his book the hidden beauty of
the microscopic world and if you want to
see more from us there's always a
subscribe button somewhere nearby